[Music]
this november dr mehmet oz famously
known for his long-running namesake tv
show will run as a trump-backed
republican candidate in pennsylvania's
senate race against democrat john
fetterman
naturally money is always a factor in
american political campaigns and dr oz
certainly acquired a fortune from his tv
days
according to a government financial
disclosure he made 9.3 million dollars
in pre-tax earnings last year alone
he also brought in just under 1 million
dollars last year for speeches and
appearances
and he has made royalties for a medical
device he patented with colleagues at
columbia university where he was a
professor of surgery
but much of oz's wealth and ties to
pennsylvania come from a different
source his wife's family
lisa oz's grandfather co-founded asplund
tree expert with his two brothers back
in 1928
asplund is now the 98th biggest private
company in america and the fifth largest
in pennsylvania
with over 33 000 employees and 4.7
billion dollars in revenue
the company trims trees for electric
utilities and municipalities and is run
by the third generation of asplunds and
owned by nearly 200 family members who
are collectively worth at least three
billion dollars
this probably helps explain why the
celebrity doctor was able to fund his
campaign with 12.1 million dollars of
personal loans and another 1.7 million
dollars in contributions
a spokesperson for asplan tree expert
told forbes the company is quote not in
any way involved in or invested in dr
oz's campaign or any other political
campaign
but did add quote individuals within the
organization may support political
parties or candidates
according to federal election commission
records at least 18 members of the
asplin clan contributed a total of 62
200 to dr oz's senate campaign on behalf
of themselves and their spouses
[Music]